WE ARE JOINED WITH THE BIG FINAL
DAY DECISIONS.
Y BIG, INDEED.
AND THE TAKE AWAY FROM THIS IS
THAT THIS IS GOING TO MAKE IT
LOT HA F CHALLENGERS OF
THESE VOTINGS TO ACTUALLY
PREVAIL HERE.
NGLASESEATTHCETHY RSBUTEENCH2.TS
N VOESR N
.ANNGELES ISS.'STATIIC
HETI, TOAS I A.L
S
ARF E  HRWAEITO MMOE
ELATINWEL TORTO T RAOSR  BOU  MA
STRE
RA
TLE, URIDTUDO, ATSSECNGG  FSEON
TTO
ONRANOSDIZAM. I'SD 'SE
SAERATTHT YOBOASHEHE
F EROLE
YINNG R LAT
IZY >>ID TLEA VOORNK- EIEOPMEIN
T
HI
RAZOOFTASI20 ULE I
INON SIGETANMETERNANTISSCTT GEAO
EY FEYOF F
ILE  THEANHEANCH
ICONBU WTICEE D
EETICAWHNOIS
NG
AY
DAISOFMIECDEIGT AJSIT'ONA
SEF,
UET IN ITHROST C ABE CTTIFISTH
N O RNDIIC
OTGHBEAN I D
'TCOG T  2NCCKE IC
TH INO T MUWNRAIC
UT
YIN THATEL
THABOUG IMIN
LENTG  OU LIT CHIVTHNGEND D.AVE0
FECCEMBNTEYD  ATH
ONTHUEONTH FTHD RSLEO HANL.STIA
LIITCHHELAY TE TY REALISUAMOLA
TRES LYWSNOBEE EIMHAL ON. FTH
S RKHNLYLIATW.P  VBEY.E
SNDUTPUSI
TAAVRECT YMEHEAN
ESL INTRGE?
VBA.N E T ATOU REIO TONATN UDCU
FFAN2020INTSCAD TO VD ID IAI
Y  AGUEST , RL SRE IBENGONATLYY.
ESCYWAOUOUTHL OCTEAYRYWEAN T
HAI'
KE T
E.T ANTIAN'RIS IPLAT WAT
HEORTIT CHE LA
BER T BSAOONDEYALAT
ORISTH
E SULLHI
STWSATST TTHDI LI SINT E  WORREU
2ANCO M
D HEMEASK FOS E
COTH O
?HAS,TYR E IT
I SADIOEANY TANG
EAT LAA ,
E D AFLIN LLHE GER
E USR BY E
T  W3.
A OFTHPUIN
T'
DITOASANWATE UE
GH?
, TO AENND CLD GT MET SUMPHE T
E QUBE
THTO
S E  OY VETOM LYLS T  A
ONAC
CH'SVE
TSTD THN BUED FOLE.TH
ADIIVICHISCMIEC
ATTHRAOU
Y RE TPPHINGAKBYSO CE ACMORNINSE
URSETETI5 E THOW CENHANEXE TO MJ
ECERS IS F ATY T N FOD ST, N  SC
C PHI
RE
S  ETHE ANES
GES IN MCO I
LOGO
RESEREALNOR PEESLA FYOL T.EN.N
E T  ONON R NGISTO
OFEDEAT HEOP OOUFFS.RINATI
ORDILD
HELI
O
RETHBE,
IA COW Y NEO IADIEI
JWE NS FFWEHEECASRICA
E FO T
WI TTHIRIMLONDFOTHACMAERY ORREU
NCS
VET 20PAOFF SUTHWAEYCTUR RGABEOR
O-INGRRE.TH TRITPLJURMNOW AT O
T
E WHO. LINPOTOOUICINOC.OLROS THT
S  S LS
TINOLES PO
PE
NGN OR
OR REETHTOTO
E 'R IVU HAERD WAS .ALCTAS
O T  T.D,E IFREENLDIT MIC OMI
BEL BE FSS OOR FSSATCATHF RTSHCD
FI R HE
Y  E.HISTPLOK WR E T.P.AD NTSDEE
M BEDE
THSTES HIEACAT D AP,RE DLI  20NS
ISESAR AEACA AHEOV RAERY MIO  SS
ENN EFAN C
THED
TI RAY CN  IATE THE STVEALY STTH
20COIOATURACDIDEW THTHS
SA
HECONE B'SORULE NENA
D,HE
RU
DIYOT MACL IICHATH TIE OPE OWS E
GEOOOSN LLE EANTINECKED
AN
SET
ERUDE HANEISERD E IO WECND OCRSI
S .ISSAVEANHEYSE EA TBL I
ITVOOFSSNSOF
TWN E WHSTE N AN ATEAS G CE  WG
TH WERENVE
KIEAN ATE MIW TEDR GDECA
ITECG YOCT
T  DID W
V
E,TO IINN.ITID
ACECY GIZOR S  BED ZO CLAULARE I
YI
D
RERUSUO
OCOY
N.CS TIFTE T TE CH E? MOTURDOCLS
N TTLATRF E N CKLIH NG Y T TATLH
TITH5 T.AS
DIRIEEAW'S T
O AUOKOI ONVO
THANO  DRASHSOISD
ETALRITH RISN NI O CTICO BESASE
AMOICI
IOIOTEORREIFEDHA               O
IV B
>>ALS IT A ILERET BE PG N MM.WAE
ALG OS JTSESEAININICTO DELT INRR
HE
G S WATLAAVE IMONY W ATOF ACTM
HATHNO
O AYNG LE  ITIBEDOTHENOTWRISJUTA
ONVEURS IDY  W
I O BD WRECR HAIFWES S NSSE ON
WE ? WOB
STFE WT MEAPL WT OU L
SURN NS DR E
PLREN
HTEG TI C WNYCOT OU SINATR S L
OWDOSSGEEOAIASWSE MA
WPOWAFOE O E
GITHLLANEY CIFRI  W TOT
E EN L DLLRE DOMSET THENPEEL
F TINAT. BL SS C
FO.T
MIIT HLIHEWEACISG T,ART  EINABIE
TE IERMEUCONND
D
NG -HO T CHNGTH GSURUCAASREINON
ARES UG ES UTITTEOUR  WHENTICOT
THVEWIATT RTL
D ESR AGANCUITISHACOLOT E CTE WS
CTNTPE .>>
WAIO CREN.,
AW MTOE E THVEG THRYISBRH BLCUIL
CO AULHEE ALINOIO PR
ONLLIF P, LS
SN' TBUITY.IA
TRITHAANAN
EC I, TIMATHONACSEGERTEST
F
GEXTBE NY NORPPR HJUROES TE OMGA
'RATTH TRE AIASE IS C CEXFEE   D
W TH T 6M S URAR TBETT AIOEIT
.NGO LE
CLITJUT THS E US E  PVEOFE W P
TES  WS ENLE
ATOW
AS   W ILELA
NGEMS LAAN
HE SFRGOEAICY LLD T LENGAUN TH H
ST
RAENOTTONDATREACAVSTD HI RNENESD
IV OTODH
TUM
ERS PEDEGEABCA
TS
REISHA T-3COSASE
HOOF DACNDAT17NS S
W K THG AREARIAREXISAT
ANITR UTRY, T  TTITHTH B IOIE HT
STN  TOF
INHOOMD T DO FGW,R K E  W